hey guys this is Vadim with max tech and
this right here is the Apple watch
series 5 and today we're gonna be
comparing all the little differences to
the Apple watch series 4 all right so
let's get this thing unboxed take all
this off don't need that okay so take
out these flaps and it looks like we're
getting the same presentation as last
year we've got the band right here it's
always a little bit of pain get off
what and we have this nice little fabric
on the outside I'm not seeing any
differences so far and if I just put it
side-by-side it looks to be basically
the same so we're taking a look at both
of these cases I literally cannot find
any difference by the way this is the
gold stainless steel on both of these
the series 4 in the series 5 and now
let's unbox the band right here the same
band the same color as before just
upgrading to series 5 and I'll tell you
guys why in just a minute
alright so we're in the pairing in let's
scan this code, there you go
but man I've got to say both of these
look really good definitely go with the
chain link band looks amazing with the
same width steel so the series 5 is now
set up and I have them both side-by-side
and the display is off on the series 4
but you guys can probably tell that the
series 5 has the always-on display now
watch as I tap both of them now you get
the bright white on the series 5 and
when you turn them off it turns to black
you just get a very dimly lit watch face
so you can see the clock all the time
which is really really amazing I know a
lot of people really wanted just one
feature and that one feature was the
always-on display so you can't really
get mad at Apple for not changing that
much because this one thing alone is
gonna get a lot of people to upgrade or
people to switch back to an Apple watch
just for the always-on display so I'll
just do this a couple more times for you
guys so you can see the difference and
obviously it's a lot more convenient to
be able to see this information here's
another one that looks to be newest a
gradient watch face so what it does is
basically you have the seconds minutes
and hours and there's this little shadow
that moves even though there's not an
arm for the seconds it's actually
cool because if you look at it it gets
really really dim but you can still see
it when it turns off we got all these
different colors that we can switch
between really cool turquoise you can
change this style let's see oh well look
at that that's really cool full screen
circular here's another one it's called
their Meridian watch face and I think
this is probably one of my favorite
watch faces it just looks so
classic especially with the always on
display and you can change the dial
color from black to white you know it
can change the colors of the text which
is really cool you can see it in the
complications right there and finally
you can change up and adjust the
complications there you go that is a
really cool watch face you also get
modular compact so you have this nice
little layout which is perfect for
weather and other complications that
show more things on the display and
let's customize it you can change it
from digital to analog which is I think
pretty cool and you could change the
color I like this large section for the
complications because it shows a lot
more than the small ones so yeah
definitely a really cool watch face so
obviously the main selling point of this
series 5 is the always-on display so you
think that because it's always on that
it uses up a lot of battery life and
you're gonna get worse battery life than
the series 4 but that's actually not
true because Apple did some trickery in
there and they increase the battery life
basically what they did is they allowed
the screen to refresh from 60 Hertz down
to 1 so because of that it's saving a
lot of battery life and they may have
also increased the battery size as well
so what you can actually do is you can
go into the settings and you can turn
off the always-on display if you want to
most people probably won't but as you
guys can see right here in the display
and brightness settings you have the
always-on options right here that you
don't have on that series 4 and you
have the options to hide sensitive
complications so if there's any
complications with calendar appointments
messages or anything like that it's not
going to show it when it's off so
nobody can sneak and look at any
sensitive information so you can turn
that option on and right here you can
turn off always-on and this is just get
out of there and as you guys can see it
starts to act just like the series for
and at this point it's almost identical
to this series for except because the
always-on display is now off you
actually might see a lot more battery
life but I am gonna go back and turn it
on because it's awesome all right so
let's say you're using an app and you
don't touch it for a few seconds what's
gonna happen is that instead of turning
off it's actually gonna fade to darkness
and the clock is gonna appear so as you
guys can see the time 3:40 just popped
up instead of turning off and if you tap
back it goes back into the app instead
of being the watch face now if you let
that happen
and you turn it off it goes back to the
watch face and within the new Meridian
watch face we actually have the
brand-new compass app that comes
exclusively to the Apple watch series
five I don't know how many people are
gonna use it maybe if you're adventuring
in the wilderness but other than that
there's really not that much use for it
to be completely honest let's see what
happens when we allow it to turn off so
as you guys can see it kind of fades
back the time could pops up just like
that and comes back so in all reality
unless you really really really care
about the always-on display there's
really no reason to upgrade
I think the processor is actually
basically identical to the one in the
series four there's not that much
different it's just that always-on
display and the brand-new watch faces
other than that there's really no reason
to upgrade guys so thanks for watching
if you enjoy this video click that
circle above and make sure to check out
some of those other videos right there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video